[Music]
today's question comes from sandra in
virginia my husband and i have been
married seven years and this is the
second marriage for both of us
when we first got married he was in
several fantasy football leagues and did
not work full-time he's been working
full-time for four years now and he's
cut back to one fantasy football league
he's cut back cut back that's a great
language i have no issue with watching
games however the 15 plus hours a week
that goes into following pro football is
a bit much
growing up my father frequently bet on
horse races losing quite a bit of money
and time to this addiction because of
this i'm very much against gambling as
i've seen it destroy people and families
could you please set the record straight
regarding if buying into brackets and or
fantasy football is a wise financial
slash life choice oh sandra sandra
um
i've got a bunch of friends in my life
that are like your husband
oh man so we can answer your money
question here this is very much not a
money question
um
this is a conversation that y'all two
need to sit down and have on a couple of
different levels one level being
regardless of what the
the issue is fantasy football watching
football cooking i want to go back to
school i want to quit my job and start a
calligraphy business whatever it is
something is setting off an alarm system
that you have that's been there since
you were a little girl because of some
behaviors that your dad did
and the old
you marry your unfinished business is
often true um really often true and
you've married your unfinished business
and now you've got alarms setting off
because your husband reminds you a lot
like your dad and you've lived in the
aftermath right you've had to live in
the ashes of the life that you're dead
gambling and destroying families
destroying people being addicted losing
a lot of money all those things
and so number one you have to recognize
you are you're dragging your past here
your body's responding to stuff in the
present that happened in the past and
you got to be honest with yourself about
it and more importantly you got to be
honest with your husband about it
and that is number two which is your
husband's hiding and running from
something he is living an alt-life they
call it fantasy
right just because it doesn't have elves
and
mushrooms and dragons flying around
using other grown men as pawn pieces
instead of being married i'm not against
fantasy football that's what you want to
do rock it on but living in that world
instead of living in the real world
which is your wife and your kids in your
home
is a problem it's a distraction it's an
addiction it is numbing out it's
disappearing right so there needs to be
some sort of conversation where both of
y'all get away from this not in a fight
don't bring the stuff up when you're
already upset but getting away and
saying hey
what's the what is the picture of our
marriage what is our vision for this
thing gonna look like because right now
i'm losing
a lot of hours to you to
pretending you are a coach of pretend
teams using real other grown men as the
player pieces right
and so
i think y'all got to get away and have
some hard hard scary conversations about
what
connection looks like for you what a
relationship looks like for you what
football versus hiding versus
entertaining versus running what that
looks like you'll need to have a hard
hard conversation and george when it
comes to
is buying into brackets or fantasy
football a why is life financial choice
i don't like to look at it like that as
much as it's a hobby it's entertainment
yeah it's a game right so if you're
gonna put money aside for going to the
movies or going out to dinner it's it
goes in that category yeah until it
becomes
i got four leagues and i don't see my
kids i don't hang out with my wife
because i'm in the basement it's a
part-time job that's exactly right and
so that that's what worries me the most
uh even more than any money spent here i
don't know if it's hundreds or thousands
of dollars i mean we have some people
around the office they like to do a
bracket it's fun they throw in 25 bucks
and it's just a fun thing
and to me i'm like okay that's great if
you can budget for that and you're debt
free and this is fun money coming out of
your entertainment part of your budget
that's okay i don't know that he can get
there right now if he can just leapfrog
to that point because this does feel
like addiction level
um and i i would question is the
priority here marriage or fantasy
football and 15 hours a week i don't
know that he's seeing much of his wife
if he's working full-time right
and so no there's nothing wrong with
fantasy football and yeah it can be a
really dumb financial choice if you're
sinking money and time into this thing
that could be better spent elsewhere i'm
sure you guys have other financial
priorities uh over you know using pawns
in a football scheme with you know 25
year old dudes i mean it just feels like
there should be more to life than this
and i i'm not against sports right
people spend a lot of money on sports
and going to games and season tickets
and all that stuff's fun but not when it
takes over your marriage right and i'm
i'm a man i'm a
i'll be the first guy i'm one of the
loudest voices in the country about
especially with men need to get together
and hang out with friends and be
together with friends in reality if well
if fantasy football binds you together
great man have some guys but y'all get
together once a week right you get
together and
finishing football is awesome for some
really remarkable long
uh
text message threads where everybody's
talking trash and everyone's you know
bringing up all the high school stuff
everyone's getting into it with each
other that's a blast
when you are spending 15 hours 20 hours
a week researching and studying and
trying to get the insides and on the sub
sub subreddit threads
yeah and your wife is sitting there
saying
what about me yeah that's a relationship
problem that's tough